apple's been working on a display that
is literally going to revolutionize the
entire display industry with not only a
massive 7k resolution but also with mini
led xdr brightness and a built-in a13
ship to support the latest apple
ecosystem features even if you're using
an intel machine so in this video i'm
gonna break down all of the leaks and
rumors and explain how it's all gonna
work including the pixel count the
thunderbolt cable situation the features
the cost and of course the release stain
now getting right into the leaks it all
began back in december when dylan dkt
leaked that there were three new apple
displays in the works a 24 inch a 27
inch and a 32 inch pro display xdr
successor now of course we know we
finally got the 27 inch studio display
at apple's march event but that still
leaves the other two so let's jump into
the rest of the leaks on march 4th
knightfi mac released some exclusive
leaks concerning a new display that has
a higher resolution than the pro display
xdr which is crazy because that model
already has a 6k resolution and
apparently 95 mac was able to confirm
with their sources that the new display
has 7k resolution and in their opinion
they think apple can either keep the
display size the same 32 inches but with
higher pixels per inch or go with a
larger 36 inch size but before i give
you guys my thoughts on this question
we've got some more leaks to go through
on april 17th mark german released his
power on newsletter and discussed a
brand new display coming yes he said
that a new 7k display is in the works
which will probably be announced later
this year alongside the new mac pro and
that's literally from last week so it
shows mark's confidence in the mac pro
coming this year instead of next year
which is something that ming chu quo
predicted and in terms of the details he
believes it'll have a 7k resolution
potentially a webcam and some new ios
ties that were featured in the low end
studio display monitor and if you really
think about it it wouldn't make sense
for apple to release the display by
itself so it would have to be coming
alongside another high-end mac and the
only mac that it makes sense to launch
with is of course the mac pro since
that's exactly what apple did last time
in 2019 with the pro display xdr so
because of that i think this new display
will be a direct replacement of that 6k
display except with 7k resolution and
some new features like a built-in webcam
but before i get into all of those
specifics including the exact resolution
and size of the display that i'm
expecting there is still one more
display that is unaccounted for from
dylan dkt's leak which would be a 24
inch display well first of all mark
german recently said that he doesn't
expect there to be a new lower priced 24
inch display because he doesn't expect
apple to want to offer a small display
like that anymore with them really
trying to push the 27-inch studio
display but wait there might actually be
another 27-inch studio display update in
the works because the most reliable
apple display analyst in the game ross
young has been predicting a new 27-inch
mini led display for months already
which he initially thought was an imac
pro but later admitted that it might
just be an external display with a
built-in ship now when i asked him about
it a couple of months ago he let me know
that a new 27-inch display was coming in
june with a release date of as late as
september and he also said he expected
it to launch alongside the mac pro in
june so what i ended up doing a couple
of days ago was ask him if that display
might actually be the new 7k display
that mark recently leaked but nope he
said that there is still one more 27
inch display with mini led technology
that is in the works and of course it's
not the studio display that we just got
which lacks mini led so with that said
i've been thinking about it a lot and i
think i finally figured out how apple's
display lineup is gonna work we're gonna
have the 1600 27 in studio display at
the low end and then at 27 inch studio
display pro for around three thousand to
thirty hundred 800
which will basically be an upgraded
version of the low end display but with
mini led and potentially 120 hertz pro
motion technology making it a huge deal
for people who like smooth animations
and gaming and then finally we're gonna
have the new 7k pro display xdr which
will start at around 6 000
with the stand which is basically the
same price as the current 6k model if
you include the stand of course and now
let's get into all of the technical
specs that i'm expecting it to come with
first of all i think the display size
will stay the same exact 32 inch size
that we already have in the current pro
display xdr with the same chassis the
same lattice pattern design on the back
but maybe with some other unique design
details to me this makes the most sense
because i believe apple will be reusing
the lattice pattern on the new mac pro
because it's iconic and is just a great
design that makes sense for great
cooling and on the plus side reusing the
same exact 32 inch chassis will save
apple a lot of money
which they'll probably need to do
because making a groundbreaking new 7k
panel is not going to be cheap i think
this makes sense because if apple
chooses to stick to the same 218 ppi as
before the display size would go up to
36 inches which i think is way too big
because the 32 inch model is already
very big and heavy and i personally
think that it's big enough instead i
believe that apple will simply pack that
7k resolution into the same 32 inch
panel size and focus on giving it more
pixels per inch and if you think that's
crazy apple's latest 14 and 16 inch
macbook pros both now come with
254 pixels per inch so if we gave the
new 7k display a target of 254 ppi that
would give us a new resolution of 7086
by
3980
pixels being slightly higher than 7k
resolution and giving us a massive 28
million 244 796
pixels which is absolutely insane and if
you want some perspective on how much
that really is it's basically 3.4 times
more pixels than standard 4k it's 91.5
percent more pixels than 5k and
38.7 percent more pixels than 6k and the
craziest thing of all is that i believe
they're going to be able to power it
with a single cable yes just one
thunderbolt 4 pro cable from the display
going to your mac and i am sure of that
because i believe this display will
stick to the standard 60 hertz refresh
rate because it'll be meant for the real
professionals doing photography and
videography work who don't really care
that much about 120 hertz and now if
you're wondering why i think this
display will revolutionize the industry
it's because there's gonna be nothing
else like it for around the same price
dell did create their 32-inch 8k monitor
a couple of years back and it's now on
sale for 3 800 which honestly isn't bad
but it has a couple of problems that the
new 7k pro display xdr is going to fix
first of all it actually requires you to
connect two display cables at the same
time because when it was made there
wasn't enough bandwidth in one cable to
make it work but with apple's 7k display
one thunderbolt 4 pro cable is going to
be all you'll need because of display
stream compression support and if you
really think about it the dell 8k
display actually has around 7.7 k
resolution which is about 17.5 more
pixels than the 7k pro display xdr so
it's not that big of a deal going from
7k to dell's 8k going further even
though the dell has higher resolution
the major drawback is that it's only
rated for up to 400 nits of brightness
because it just uses a basic lcd display
panel while the 7k pro display xdr will
use mini led technology to give you up
to 1600 nits of brightness for true hdr
playback and editing which is something
that's not possible on dell's 8k display
and of course it'll lead to much better
contrast and deeper blacks even while
not using hdr and then finally the
design and build quality of the pro
display is obviously going to be much
nicer especially since apple is likely
to pack in a built-in webcam and special
ios based features as well and once
again i think it's going to be showing
off alongside the mac pro at wwdc and
maybe even alongside the studio display
pro with 120 hertz if apple decides to
give their users a couple of different
options based on what they like but i
guess we're just gonna have to wait and
see so with all that said let me know
your thoughts on this new display down
in the comment section below and if you
enjoyed the video go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out one
of those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]